kailani do that thing damn gummy worms
won't open sorry I'm feeling a little
aggressive this the morning Hey Oh baby
is it like the top one it's here
oh yeah oh there's spacers right there
we go oh no don't use your fingers we
got the other yeah we have our alright
yeah we're not even tweezing or just
small icons
[Music]
Iko myself are super busy working on
these other big projects like lifeline
now every once a while people come to us
saying hey guys you make cool videos
would you like to make a cool commercial
for us and sometimes really yes
sometimes were like hey we're actually
hecka busy just making original stuff
thankfully Jake's got the chops finally
so he decided to go out to the desert
with much of machine guns and trucks and
really really expensive cinema gear and
shoot have really big commercial I'm
really hoping that I don't disappoint
Sam and Nico or tarnish the good
corredor name because this will be my
first commercial directing experience I
actually see this as a really really
cool opportunity the problem is if I
mess it up I'll never get to do this
again
everyone's just kind of finishing
breakfast and then I want to go over
with these model toys from my childhood
what we're gonna do it picture card
camera car yeah give it's alive yeah my
thumb was pushing down while orbiting
well Darrin's good well at least you
just broke the rotors it actually
relates something surprisingly still
intact I thought you just ruined our
phantom for today now it looks like the
best run on this is kind of at an angle
like this so we get all that in the
background you'll stay at a consistent
speed just drop the crane down turn so
that we get this nice sort of like
what's up brother you got some dust on
your lens oh this is that we can get
some amazing swooping shots around the
car in the car just show off this mighty
vehicle that we have this is the the red
epic with the optimal 18 to 91 some
still look pretty good
I'm Jarrod de Gato with corridor digital
again we're here in the desert we've got
an amazing armored personnel carrier
they've always got great food here gun
turrets and breakfast burritos and I
hear there's like a pretty bitchin
toilet there on the RV
what are you used to put us for you
today a badass [ __ ] that's who I
suppose the bit that's the good life
here you get to see these amazing
locations have a great time you see my
brand new boots if I'm going in I'm
gonna always stop
[Music]
ten do you wake up this morning couple I
didn't go to sleep I went straight from
work to hear great sounds fun yeah
take a nice bumpy nap here gonna be a
great day for you yes Carmichael like
what the [ __ ] are you doing here
today's a good day to kill somebody I'm
ready to rock let's do this [ __ ] I was
talking about eating and talking about
how [ __ ] awesome corridor digital is
but now I'm on another burrito so the
stabilization of the camera it should be
fun alright it's meant to take some some
wiggle so yeah should be be great you're
gonna love it you're gonna love it
I'm really looking forward to hopping
into the camera car and seeing how these
shots turn out the one sort of x-factor
that we're up against right now is how
bumpy the ground will be out there
add some smooth camera motion to it's my
favorite song is called jackin the-box
by ice cube because the first line is
I'm a superhero
like Lou Ferrigno and that's run the
family so now getting my own song but
seeing that when I workout because it
motivates me to become a super hero a
wonderful piece of motor technology
mixed with camera technology this is
what's heaven you get to do all the time
me I'm going to be controlling the
camera or where the camera is pointing
Ryan over here is going to be
controlling the focus and zoom Russell
here is going to be controlling the
actual jib arm and Kris is going to be
driving us mr. Wattson will be uh yes
hahaha what happened ah that's better
yeah we lost power no tom oh is it
uh-huh
that's awful there we go here we go we
had to stay to the commenters you say
that you say Oh what um do I wait have
you seen that how I Met Your Mother
episode where Robin Scherbatsky says but
um and people turn it into a drinking
game but um the best things ever said
ever started with an um um
I came I saw a couple of times in some
of the bumps the camera powered off but
the Preston stayed active and then we
switch it from brick in the back so just
this guy can you get the day with you I
can it felt secure but like we hit a
people hit a bump you can start shooting
when you got the truck over there right
well yeah there's a couple things the
bounce I'm a little worried about the
bounce so I want Ben he's going right
now to dump it and to throw it in
premier and catch me I don't want to
grab a bunch of footage to start
shooting until we know that for sure
yeah
exact
and here's a little valley yeah dude
it's just super cool so go later and go
further in the shot
no stabilization on there I think it's
gonna be fine yeah and we have extra
data on the sides it's gonna be fine
yeah just keep shooting at 5k you'll be
go yeah all right please how's it
working - [ __ ] awesome yeah
rule number one we're moving when we're
not shooting he's sitting and holding on
I feel good I'm inside the picture car
right now difference between the camera
car in the picture car is camera car
literally has a camera on it picture car
is the one in front of the camera the
one that's going to be shot like a
picture behind that the thing are the
actors they will be riding the back our
friend del here will be our expert
driver while Jann and Jake are in the
back of the camera truck getting sweet
sweet pictures I used to be a tow truck
driver I did that for 22 years
when David stop watch me and take
pictures of me I used to walk up to them
and tell them you're gonna pay me you
can take my picture you got a paid
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look [ __ ] awesome there do you do
your hair looks amazing
just you look like a black metal singer
yeah we got a ton of great stuff there
now we're gonna have lunch and then
after lunch we're gonna hop up with
Steadicam on the back of the car
shoot that section out for an hour to
before the end of the day one two and
then and then we'll move to him Oh his
majestic hair camera right good
he's also frame right right yeah
everyone's still looking uh left yeah
they're looking frame left so yeah he's
still camera okay commies foot day going
dusty but fantastic pick up later.this
people lots of Chinese food all the dust
unity we're getting there okay what did
he do to you it's better if it's on me
talk to me nothing I don't do the Suzy Q
did you check it again that's late no
block the RAM buddy go ahead
that's why here
and you shall learn coat it Galloway
move brick no
point out to point up here we go
you have it yeah you're done over trying
to eat til I'm done again I might go
with him holding so innocently that's a
wrap on Lu and Coty do that again you
can't read that water is warm
that's better
just got those great a testosterone two
days ago the child was born the daughter
from that having just went from nan to
Parenthood do you think it's oh it's
just like a bit but it changes you a
little bit changes you a little bit do
you
seriously go to jail by just forgetting
one thing right like oh [ __ ] I forgot to
feed her today and your jingle look so
not it's not your pet Liz yeah exactly
yeah we were like alright Jake and we
put him in a car we slap the seat belt
on him to send him out in the middle
desert and there he found himself a
bunch of camera gear and a bunch of cool
trucks and guns and filmed himself his
very own commercial
so congratulations Jake he also just had
a baby so he just had his first baby and
of his first commercial big steps for
Jake while we're in here playing guitar
working on scripts how'd you lose your
finger ah bar fight and Peru steak bit
it off of uh you know I was never able
to tell